alright so we've talked about
evangelicals already and the rise of
evangelicals and some of the things that
make them you know what will we tal what
does it mean a big Victorian does it
have any resonance with with you and
short of them with me so I'd be super
surprised if it really meant anything
determinate for you does anybody have
any sort of sense about what it might
mean to be Victorian yeah my studies
minor we talked about how gender the
separate spheres doctrine men when they
really developed or in between age
that's okay that if that's a part of
this that's a very important part of
this on mainly it's something happy to
do it like upper middle class and upper
class right because the working class
still had a woman's let me out the
workplace working the same sort of
crappy jobs that a lot of amended but
for for your right to the Victorian age
there's a very strong separation of the
janitors so women are more and more
being confined to the space with a home
and better out in the workplace that's
one of the central ideas oftentimes we
associate Victorian ISM with a kind of
moral prudishness a kind of
squeamishness about sexuality about
conflict about all sorts of things
Victoria is our seen as beings are like
the modern-day Puritans and then that
and there's some justice to that but the
not not complete this error was actually
quite a firm's as your book points out
it's a time of urbanization urbanization
means that people are moving away from
sort of settled countryside living where
things moved a bit slower in the cities
and what happens when you put people in
cities you have a lot of new things
happening a lot of things breaking down
this is a process it's still going on
today in some parts of the world your
book also mentions pro
mission which we're going to talk about
quite a bit now one of the things that
you associated with the Victorian age is
reform this before the Civil War one of
the huge reform issues was anti-slavery
right makes sense that's part of a broad
about the Civil War after the Civil War
some of those energies could channel
into reconstruction into trying to
alleviate the plight of the blacks in
the south which was pretty pretty
terrible because you know white
Southerners we're not particularly happy
about losing the war and drag their
heels on just about everything but that
sort of faded out after what there were
other things ladies as most white
evangelicals turn their attention
elsewhere so where did they turn their
attention that this thing about gender
roles is an issue gender roles and sort
of split women being confined in the
household a home men work the
marketplace all those those you know
business the professions overlap the
poor like it says in both sexes we're
still consigned to hard physical work so
you've got a public versus private
dichotomy development right where do the
churches fit in with this your book
guests well the church is kind of a
blurred blurred lines type of place why
church leadership is primarily male but
who's really actively involved in the
churches it's as women and the churches
occupy kind of a weird you know in
between Leah
because the role of organized religion
was becoming confused in terms of the
dichotomies that were shaping the way
many churchgoers organize their
perceptions of reality if society to be
divided into dichotomies meaning
separate zones what was the place of the
church and there it starts talking about
this guy who contributes to these word
minds white moody what moody is the
father of modern revivalism and moody
sets up shots in Chicago as a matter of
fact there's still a a moody bible
school in Chicago that runs radio shows
and does all sorts of outreach he teams
up with this guy IRA Sankey was a
musician and songwriter and these
revivals were sort of bringing together
you know public the business together
how so well before he shows up on seeing
he insists that the entire ground be
prepared there has to be a committee of
clergy and laity that racked a
tabernacle a huge tent for the people
that are there going to be engaging the
riot of the Bible they use modern
methods of advertising and publicity so
you know what would would that be at
that time the newspapers for example
that was again it's something quite
different you know to see that newspaper
ads show up to this revival people
weren't doing that before that time a
lot of a lot of the wealthiest
businessmen were admirers of his and
sewing it says his message was very much
in harmony with the masculine world of
commerce and industry and served it's
it's a interest in the lack of
disturbing social or political
implications what's his message his
message is very very simple here's
here's the books some really it could be
reduced to the proposition that
salvation was available for the asking
all the center had to do to
and salvation was to make a simple
decision symbolized in hitting the saw
dust trail which is the frame the
framework that he used so I this is what
you throw down at that time so that
would let you know you didn't have
hardwood floors and these outdoor things
you would keep things clean so hitting a
sawdust trail meant you know coming up
to the front in the altar call and
saying yes I'm going to live a new life
so it says instead of theological
reflection his sermons were anecdotal
usually pathetic stories involving
premature death longing for mother and a
gentle Jesus whose message of redemption
was opened all judgment was gone mercy
was everything so you know what he's
what he's teaching is you know all you
have to do is open up your heart not
your mind your heart and let God in and
everything will be okay from that point
on that's what's going out of these
revivals that's the theology they're
also revolutionising things by using
music in a very different way they start
writing all sorts of songs a whole new
genre called gospel hymns like your book
points out don't confuse it with with
the African American gospel music and
stuff it's something different these
were these were hymns sort of designed
to tug at your heart strings to get you
to feel a certain way and they would do
this to warm up the audience again new
thing you know the idea was to soften
and love so you can make these
sentimental appeals so your book talks
about a cult of powerlessness going
along with us that's actually such a
good phrase I'll put on the board what
does that mean it means that the victims
the the marginalize the one down become
the ones who actually have the social
power although we in real life they're
still just as alienated just as one down
you know just a subordinate as as they
were now like your book points out not
all Victorian women were content with
sort of tradable the reform Crusades
provided women with an opportunity to
actually get involved not just in
organizations but in politics remember
this public world as the province of men
is excluding women from politics women
can't hold it this time either that's
that's one of those movements the reform
movement that comes about so one way for
women to actually get very actively
involved in politics is through some
more dynamic performance not to revive
us the three actual perform and one of
the biggest ones that captures the
imagination is it's called the
temperance so what's the temperance
movement what is it what does it involve
when you hear this word temperance does
that still have any resonances with you
I know I talked about this in my ethics
classes and we talked about the virtue
of temperance does this mean anything
today we don't use this we're very much
doing so in the past even for my
generation we didn't use this word much
I think from maybe my parents generation
your grandparents generation it would
still have residences of being tied to
alcohol so three we installed alcohol I
know you can smell alcohol temperance
originally meant like moderation and
Christianity was not necessarily
anti-alcohol as a matter of fact you
know if you think about what was the
first miracle Jesus is supposed to have
done he didn't do it you know because he
wanted to his mom Kathy y'all got on his
cage till we did it what was it yeah
exactly so it's hard to make the case
that that Christian
it is necessarily against alcohol when
you've got this guy turning water into
wine at a wedding fees that isn't a lot
of Christians actually drink quite a bit
at that time your book has an
interesting statistic here since between
1790 and 1840 the average male citizen
drink about half a pint of hard liquor a
damn so what would say half a pint is
like one of those little flasks you know
many shots are in half a point about
five shots so imagine that the average
guy is drinking about five shots of
liquor not beer not why five shots a
hard liquor a day every day some day is
more some days less maybe some guy over
here only drinks to that means some guy
over here is drinking ain't some guy
over here doesn't drink any some guys
drinking a whole pint a day that's a lot
of drinking taking place right so what's
up not that much I don't know yeah if
you're doing a day in day out that gets
pretty tough overtime I say this coming
from a state that like you know led the
nation and drinking that advantage
Johnson Randy consumption beer
consumption you know drinks in Wisconsin
I think it a bartender's license to work
at a gas station because you've sold so
much beer and wine at gas stations and
one of the things they taught us in
bartending class the 4-hour bartending
class because it was drinks in Wisconsin
were one and a half times stronger than
other places people just put in more
liquor you know so even coming from
there I think that drinking half a pint
a day this kind of all thought to drink
so now that you liked your book points
out temperance didn't originally mean
getting rid of alcohol together but that
became an absolutist position the and
its notion of taking the pledge
becomes what temperance is about taking
the pledge to what to not to drink to
swear off demon rum and it became like
your book points out this quintessential
American reform movement because
everybody could get behind it everybody
could get behind it for various reasons
it could be because you know you just
don't like people who drink that much it
could be because it makes you look good
it could be because you know you want to
change society and drinking really can
interfere misis I think it quite a bit
it could be revenge against you know the
male sex because it was mostly
identified with men so a lot of people
could get behind it and one of the big
organizations is the women's Christian
Temperance Union eventually it gets led
by this woman Frances Willard and
Willard was a real fireman she she had
this whole program she wanted not only
to shut down saloons but she campaigned
for women's interests in areas of labor
prisons prostitution drugs on you think
about all these different areas so this
is one of the key organizers she also
campaigned for women's suffrage and this
is the organization that really gets the
ball rolling on the temperance movement
later on they get sort of overshadowed
by the anti-saloon League and your books
guys a little bit of time talking about
this word saloon when we think of saloon
what do we think I'm going to the silver
must be like an Old West kind of town
it's probably got swinging doors you
know that's not all saloons work saloons
were the sort of bourbon institution
where you'd go to drink another word for
it would beat at tavern is a place where
you
go basically to drink with your buddies
after work maybe you'll have a meal
maybe not maybe your meal will just be
licked and it got associated with all
these sort of unsavory elements of urban
lunch like I said it represented all the
social forces that stood against
everything rural evangelicals and urban
progressives have in common so they talk
about this is sort of tied together with
aunty anti-catholicism of the time and
anti-catholicism was on the rise why not
only were Protestants you know because
they were Protestants going to be
against Catholics there were all these
massive waves of immigration that we're
taking place and if your view of America
is that it's a primarily Protestant
nation and you've got all these people
coming in who are you know in your view
of a different religion you're not going
to like that you're going to see that as
a dilution of your national character
and a lot of these Catholic
nationalities are congregating in the
cities because urbanism is a big concern
of the time they're not going out to the
countryside so much so the anti-saloon
movement is kind of tied in with this as
well they says the saloon help
perpetuate immigrant culture reinforced
Catholic mores it robbed the working men
of his wages sobriety health usefulness
to as a family and employer it served as
a dent in for crime of all sorts it
serves as a convenient basis for corrupt
urban machine politics it was a symbol
of everything that the better classes
wanted to get rid of so what does this
ultimately lead to what we call
prohibition the 18th amendment yeah of
course none of us are none of us even
know anybody at this point old enough to
really remember an awful lot about
prohibition because that generation is
dying out
I had a great-uncle the oldest of my
great uncle's he was actually a booze
run from from Canada to bring down stuff
across the board the M sports car fit on
the cops it was that was part of
prohibition it's got all this glamorous
stuff around cops and robbers why did
all that come up because they told
people you can't drink anymore the
entire nation is going to be dry they
managed to pass a constitutional
amendment that outlawed alcohol all
across the board that took a massive
amount of consensus among voters you
know we talked about bipartisan issues
to pass a constitutional amendment
that's a lot of work you know you can
only do that when you've got everybody
behind you more or less and the way that
they were able to do this was by
mobilizing evangelicals this was the
last major issue that evangelical
Protestants were able to all get on
board process in general were able to it
was not just the we often think of like
being against liquor and stuff like that
as a conservative thing but this is
really much more a liberal progressive
thing it was the Methodists who are
leading the charge and it was seen as
you know sort of a way to make sure that
you could take care of the the people
who would be put out by by alcohol you
know poor the working class you can make
sure that they didn't blow all their
money on booze and reinforce a moral
nation so your victim talks about what
happens after this how well did
prohibition actually work out given what
you know about American history what do
you suspect given that you can walk down
the street and go to a bar yeah I mean
you've all seen the gangster movies you
know it starts organized crime or
contributes fit more it actually has to
be repealed by the twentieth amendment
now we regulate alcohol but we don't we
don't ban it all together this is the
last like I said this is the last thing
that they can actually get all on the
same page with Protestantism divides now
into camp so far away from it
Protestantism in America divides into
two camps and you can understand these
as liberal or modernist and get a new
word coming
what's going on in culture at the time
that produces this this split well a
couple different things so I'll put like
the dividing of stuff in here what do
you associate this guy Charles Darwin
Turtles I know can we went to the
Galapagos but finches what's a wes is
real a big thing and what is that what
is that coming from very good so
Darwinian evolution and he's not the
first guy to talk about evolution by the
way plenty of people hundreds of years
before i'm already you know thinking in
evolutionary terms but he's a guy who
actually goes up and does some
scientific work and says here's what I
observe you know with these finches
here's what I've observed these Turtles
then he has a book about man what human
beings that he says that we're to send
it from the Apes not through a lot of
people because if that's true what can't
be true something that views Protestants
want to hold on to yeah like not not by
taking an eighth and you know monkeying
around which but I watch you watch out
for the language sometimes right but
just like you don't take a clay it
blowing into it and saying there you go
Adam so that literal story in the Bible
if Darwin is right that that can't be
literally true and a lot of people at
that time are saying it is literally
true so you know this is going to be a
big problem another thing that's going
on is what we call modern biblical
criticism you know many people's views
of the Bible are that it's sort of like
fell into human
eggs hands directly from the mouth of
God what we know is that it couldn't be
like that because some of the books you
know are written earlier some of the
books are written later sometimes they
refer to books that we no longer have
you read the books of kings you'll see
though the authors say oh by the way if
you wanna hear more about this King go
read the book over here which we don't
have anymore so we know that there's
there's been a history of development
modern biblical criticism means looking
at the texts not as necessarily divinely
inspired but as literature that we can
know something about that we can apply
techniques to to figure out whether you
know this part was written first this
purpose relator here's one example of
this the Book of Isaiah is one of the
longest books of the Bible and it's
named after this guy Isaiah and so for a
long time everybody thought Isaiah wrote
it well if you do careful textual
analysis of it it's probably got at
least two or three different writers one
guy wrote the first part then another
guy or perhaps a committee wrote the
second part and then another guy wrote
the third part and these were probably
written at different times and then put
together is one thing and one way that
you can make sense of this is actually
by saying there is an entire school of
Isaiah and one of the things we've often
found in ancient literature was if you
belong to a particular school you would
just attribute the founder of the school
with your writings this happened all the
time but that's something that you would
bring in because of biblical criticism
again if you think of the Bible as being
the Word of God coming directly as
revelation like God is like whispering
into the writers year as he's writing
things down that's not going to fly with
you you're not going to be okay with
that and this is one of the things
that's going to two separate liberal or
modernist
who tend to be okay with that sort of
thing and they'll say you know there's
development there's growth there is a
focus on the human as opposed to the
fundamentalists who are saying no there
there are some things that have to be
you know seemed literally so this is
involving a literal reading Scripture
there's more involved in being a
fundamentalist than that but we'll talk
a little bit more about that later out i
think when we get to that this is going
to lead to what the book calls the
second disestablishment this split we're
going to look at the split bit more
carefully in later chapters
so we had the second disestablish when
was the first disestablishment right
after the Revolution I no more state
churches everybody has to sort of
compete for adherence for believers gift
if something to bring to the table or
else nobody's going to go to your church
the second disestablishment is taking
place in part because of the split
between Protestants so they can't get on
the same page anymore over things over
social issues the way that they used to
with with prohibition there's other
things that are happening tipped portals
blur ilysm occurring through immigration
this is part of what I was talking about
before Catholics Orthodox Jews they were
they were marginalized before they were
seen as the others they're not part of
the culture because the culture was
essentially dominated by Protestant
Christians as they're becoming a larger
larger part in America their voices are
now becoming part of the history they're
becoming part of the narrative more and
more the Protestants end up getting
marginalized not really marginalized but
in their own view they see it as they're
losing their there were sort of role
another thing was what you can call
secularism but instead of saying
secularism all say secularity meaning
and emphasis on the non-religious and
your book has used these great examples
you know a lot of times like I said
people would go to revivals because
revivals where where you would get
excited that's what
when people were into you know Billy
Sunday actually turn revivals into
something almost like vaudeville he gets
eclipsed by by what by sports by
entertainment and these illustrate like
the book says the power of secular mass
culture the radio tabloids newspapers
filmed all that part of this is part of
the sort of a secular life that doesn't
have much to do with religion now we
don't think about today's radio and TV
do you have religious networks sure I
mean you can listen to Catholic radio or
seventh day adventist radio where you
can watch you know various religious
networks how many you ever like watch
that stuff if you find it entertaining
when you want you know gripping dramas
do you turn to the Bible channel are
there's cool stories in the Bible you
know a lot of the stories that you you
look at today are actually just taking
the local stories and kind of gussying
them up and changing the names and their
great stories but do we go to these
religious channels for the most part of
the for our entertainment not really and
we do have you know some people are all
talking about religion in terms of
sports don't we you know they credit
Jesus for their touchdown or you know
further attack or whatever things like
that for the most part Sports is pretty
disassociated from religion isn't it
it's actually an old Joe of that you
know if it's a super bowl all the
pastors you have to make their their
sermon really short so everybody can get
home to go get ready for the super bowl
that shows you that the tension there
there's another thing that's happening
to social functions what mean by names
like welfare taking care of the poor
social work taking care of orphans all
those sorts of things those start
becoming more matter of the government
and not so much a matter of where they
were before in the hands of churches so
that's part of what's leading to
disestablishment
another thing that that your book talks
about is issues of sexuality there's a
whole conversation that can be had about
that questions of sexuality and sex
roles preoccupied middle class women and
considerable numbers of men you may not
realize this but the YMCA and YWCA are
coming out of those conversations in
part this this you know Young Men's
Christian Association that's what why
does YMCA stance when YWCA young women's
Christian Association what was all that
about it was a way to sort of like have
bodily period so that then you could
have spiritual purity now we don't
associate with that I see something some
smirks out there probably because of the
song YMCA right and one of the other
things that's sort of an index of how
far things go how disestablished
Protestants feel you can tell the people
are upset about you know not being in
charge anymore when they start burning
things or breaking things or going crazy
and the last thing that your book
actually talks about in this chapter is
the Ku Klux Klan the Klan was originally
established in the American South right
in the eighteen 1870s and it disappears
for quite a while he revives in the
1920s and 1930s to the point that they
actually interfered with the national
election they they kept Al Smith from
getting getting elected cuz he was a
Catholic candidate who was the clan
against who the three classes three
groups that they were fundamentally
opposed to I don't know this is yummy
this isn't hard to figure out
african-americans that was that was the
original group that they were targeting
later on it shifts its emphasis
african-americans yeah non Protestants
who that include for Catholics and then
one other religious group would have
they didn't like the Mormons but at the
time they're not really on the scene so
much Jews the Klan was sort of a
nativist you know resurgence and that
came out of his second disestablishment
it's sort of the dark side of it you
might say and the the 1920s clamp spent
just as much time going after Catholics
as they did going after
african-americans you're going after
Jews and why because they felt like they
had they felt like all these things had
you know taken away Protestant America
that's where illegal